the thing with
cooking with color is that by the end of
this video my hands are going to be
rainbow colored hey everyone it's inka
as many of you know i love animation i
especially love pixar movies i also love
making dishes inspired by different
colors and today i'm gonna be doing
something a little bit different i'll be
picking five colors from the color
palette of pixar's turning red and
attempt to make a three-course meal
using only those five colors quick color
palette breakdown we have a burgundy red
shade we have a brighter vermilion shade
of red then we have a rosy petal pastel
pink and a lavender periwinkle and then
we have green the reason i'm choosing
turning red is well one i love the movie
it's one of my favorites right now i
relate to the main character maelyn so
much and two i just think it has such
like a vibrant and fun color palette
that is going to be challenging but
exciting for us to work with as you can
see these are not the easiest colors to
work with because i'm trying to use only
natural colored ingredients but we're
gonna try and do it so let's get started
to begin with i want a lot of red and
for this first dish i'm thinking red
dumplings it's just going to be this
like super vibrant red on the outside
and to get that red i'm going to use
this beet powder right here i actually
used it to make pancakes in my 24 hour
series i'm gonna make some beet water
right now just by adding the beet powder
over here i'm gonna add in some hot
water which will help this dissolve
right in here i'm going to add in my
flour slowly i'm just gonna go in with
my hands because this is how i make it
at home i have my own family recipe my
grandpa made this for me a lot as a kid
just felt really appropriate to do this
today this is now formed into a dough
i'm just gonna sprinkle my counter here
red is actually a really important color
in chinese culture it represents so many
things like joy luck happiness you know
just good fortune and i think that's
part of the reason it's like the main
color it's literally called turning red
i've been needing this for quite a while
and look at this hand this is the power
of beat everybody so now what i'm gonna
do is actually let this rest for a
little bit for around half an hour or so
we'll be right back after this is rested
all right we're back with a rested
dumpling dough and this is what my
grandpa taught me i'm going to roll it
out into a log and then we're going to
section it off into little pieces before
we roll them out into wrappers i'm going
to cut these little bits out now i
cannot tell you the amount of times i've
watched my grandpa make this this is
what he does and he does it like so much
faster than i'm doing it right now we're
just slowly rolling out the edges here
you wanna thin out the edges because
that's the part that's gonna fold
together but you don't want it to be so
thin that it breaks so this is the first
wrapper it's around this big i'm gonna
continue making some more right now so
i'm going to keep doing this and we'll
be back when i finish
all of it all right we have our dumpling
wrappers rolled out we're gonna go ahead
and take one now and i actually already
have some filling here this is a
dumpling filling that i grew up having
it's my grandpa's recipe grandpa pastor
mom passed to me i have a video on this
so you can go check that out we're gonna
go ahead and just scoop this into our
dumpling wrapper here i always end up
being too greedy here i'm going to just
put some water around the edges and then
just fold it in like so it's like
pleating it you know and you see the
beautiful thing about homemade wrappers
is that it really just does stick
together so easily and there you have a
beautiful little beet dumpling green in
the movie i feel like kind of represents
the mom mae's room is also green where
she's this like super vibrant red so
it's almost like she's trying to break
out of this system that she's in like
how you know i think her mom wants to be
calm and collected and she's like but i
have emotions so the red and green i
think is a very interesting contrast
there between her and her mom my mom and
i actually make dumplings together by
the time i make one she's already made
like five
so let me finish up here and then we can
bring the steamer in and get these going
back i have my beautiful bamboo steamer
here it's huge so normally i would
actually steam with parchment paper or
like if i have some sort of steaming
cloth with me at home but today to fit
the theme of red and green i'm gonna
steam it over cabbage all right so this
is looking good now i'm going to put my
dumplings right on top i made like
really big dumplings i was really
excited about the filling so now i'm
gonna put these right over the pot
closing in this is gonna take a couple
of minutes to steam probably a little
longer than expected because i made them
so big but um i'm excited to see how
these turn out
look at how beautiful that red is so i'm
gonna plate this on here and i also have
some chives and chili oil i think i'm
just excited because i'm hungry why did
i make them so big what am i gonna do
can i fit them all look at how big this
is oh my god here you go this is what it
looks like all right i'm gonna put some
chili oil right in here and once again
to fit our color palette we're gonna add
a sprinkle of green in the form of
chives so melin and her mother are
one and there you have it that is the
first dish of our three-course meal but
for now we're gonna go ahead and work on
our second course we're back and i have
moved on to the main dish of our
three-course meal it's called hong sao
roll so the first step i'm doing here is
just melting some rock sugar in some hot
oil this is to help caramelize the pork
belly which we're going to add later the
pork belly here has already been
blanched for a few minutes this is
looking kind of melted you can see that
the sugar has now become little puddles
of golden brown so this is where i'm
going to add in the pork belly so i'm
gonna let this just sit for a little bit
what i thought was really cool too about
turning red and the foods featured in it
is that the team and the art team
specifically actually put a lot of
effort into doing research for
everything you see in the film i was
also talking to the director domeshi
briefly and she told me that most of the
dishes featured in the movie are a
combination of taishanis and cantonese
cuisine another thing that i forgot to
bring up earlier about the dumplings is
that the dumplings featured in turning
red are actually an homage to her mom's
background from the north of china it is
a beautiful golden brown i have both
light soy sauce and dark soy sauce so
adding both of those in and also some
rice wine i believe this is shaoxing
rice wine now i'm just going to add in
the water and i know that's a lot of
water but we're going to be braising
this we're going to be cooking this down
around like 45 minutes or so so i'm
going to let this do its thing and we're
gonna get started working on our rice so
again to stick with the color palette
that we have today i'm thinking we can
make purple rice which i have done
before for i only ate purple foods for
24 hours to change it up a little bit
and i'm actually going to dye my white
rice and uh purple cabbage what we have
here is just sliced purple cabbage that
we've boiled for 15 minutes and then
steeped again for 15 minutes i'm gonna
use this liquid to cook my rice so i'm
gonna first strain this so i'm gonna go
ahead and put my rice in here first and
then we're just gonna fill this up it
looks like i put like so much food dye
in here but this is really truly just
purple cabbage itself gonna let this
rice cook i think pork belly is pretty
much done and we can plate this up i
have some cilantro here on my plate so
now we're going to plate up our pork
belly so we're going to just place that
on here we're serving this up family
style hence the plating that's why i'm
plating everything in i'm not eating
this all by myself i promise or maybe i
am who knows i'm only going to put one
bowl of rice for now just so you guys
can see what it looks like but this is
my purple rice look at that here's our
second course we have one more course to
go through gonna be dessert it's gonna
be sweet it's gonna be fantastic so brb
i'm thinking donuts so remember that one
breakfast scene where maylin's mom ming
prepares the kanji you know the
breakfast porridge and then she also has
this little box of donut holes so
there's like both eastern western food
on a table which is something i feel
like i grew up with so fun fact the
donuts from the movie are actually from
tim hortons and they actually have this
product called timbits so today i'm
going to make something kind of like
timbits so even before i go into making
the donut holes i'm going to make some
homemade sprinkles because we really
want to be sure to to get those colors
right i'm going to be making both purple
and green sprinkles with different food
colorings natural food colorings purple
we're doing ube and then for green we're
going with this pandan extract so we're
going to get started by having some
powdered sugar here and to this powdered
sugar i am going to add in a tablespoon
of water and i'm going to put in corn
syrup the thing with cooking with color
too is that by the end of this video my
hands are going to be rainbow colored so
oh accidents happen and that's okay i
think we have roughly a teaspoon of oop
extract here oh okay see i was afraid
that i was going to put too much but i
feel like this should be okay so far and
for those of you who are not familiar
with the flavor of ube it's kind of like
vanilla but also like coconut-ish so
here's what we have so far i'm going to
now put this in the piping bag so then
we can pipe out our sprinkles this is
the part where you need real steady
hands okay here we go i'm gonna put
these into straight lines and then we're
gonna have to break this up into
sprinkle form i think i'm pretty much
finished with my purple sprinkles here
i'm going to now do the same thing with
my pandan extract the green ones and
we're just going to fill the rest of
this up we actually need to dry this for
around six hours or so luckily i have an
incredible culinary team who has already
prepped some for me so i'm gonna swap
these out and then we can go into making
the donut hose now to make the actual
donut batter i'm gonna start with some
flour and then baking powder
sugar and salt dry ingredients in one
bowl and then wet ingredients in the
other bowl i have some milk here i'm
gonna plop in my egg yolks one egg yolk
put in a little bit of vanilla extract
whisk this really quickly together now
i'm just going to combine the two
together until we have a batter i'm
gonna go into adding my melted butter
here and this batter is more of like a
clumpy thicker batter i think this looks
pretty good it is now a very sticky
dough so now that this is done i am
going to start frying my donut holes
frying station is now ready and set up
so i have a little ice cream scoop here
this is what i'm going to use to scoop
out my donut batter
all right it's in it's in a tin this
just really helps make sure that it's
all evenly sized these don't have to be
in here for that long just around two
minutes or so until they're nice golden
brown okay these are now a beautiful
brown
so i'm gonna take them out before they
burn so now i'm gonna go ahead and
finish frying up the rest of this and
then we can go into decorating making
the glaze my donut holes are ready and
they've cooled down then i'll set this
here for now while i work on the glaze
which we will make into a light pastel
pink which actually apparently the
pastel pink colors and purple were
inspired by sailor moon it's like a very
dreamy transformation the film is
supposed to be set in the early 2000s so
it's kind of like you know that like boy
band pop culture fun tween energy so
we're just going with that kind of vibe
here light pink is sort of the running
theme that we also see in turning red
you remember those like pink clouds that
kind of poof up when may turns into the
red panda it's kind of like a
transformation thing it's very dreamy in
order to try to make this light pink i
am using a combination of both
strawberry powder and beet powder give
this a gentle toss just to make sure all
the colors are in here and then now i'm
going to add in my milk when i was a
teenager of course i was into boy bands
i feel like everybody goes through that
phase you know like did i have posters
on my wall at one point no because my
mom wouldn't let me but did i want to go
to a concert and like sneak out
i didn't sneak out i asked for
permission i'm
oh yeah it looks really good i'm gonna
dip my donut holes in here and then
we're gonna sprinkle some purple and
green sprinkles on there look at that
beautiful before it dries up i'm going
to quickly sprinkle some green and
purple sprinkles on here all right
amazing i hope tim horton is proud here
we are our final course for our
three-course meal these beautiful pink
purple green donuts i think it's time to
bring everything else in so you guys can
have the full picture of what this
entire meal looks like okay here we have
the whole meal and all five colors
burgundy red vermillion red lavender
periwinkle pastel pink and emerald green
playing with natural food coloring can
always be a little bit intimidating and
you never really know what to expect but
i feel like the colors really came
through
dumplings obviously amazing oh my god
homemade wrappers are chewy and cute and
this sauce oh my god pork belly look at
how shiny it is
because it's been braised it's so tender
eat it with some rice
this purple cabbage hack is just
incredible last but not least gotta try
my donuts
very good my free dried strawberries oh
my gosh thank you guys so much for
watching i had so much fun if you have a
movie you love and that you want us to
try cooking with their colors let us
know in the comments below otherwise we
will see you next time bye
you